i think that today we live in a world
that is you know what connects me with
other people it's our passion it's our
professional passion it's not where i'm
located geographically so you know i can
have a great calling you know in africa
and we can write together books and you
know we can do research together there's
no borders actually you know in science
and so i really love it when you connect
to people that you know you actually
have the same goals and motivations and
you can you know have this wonderful
collaboration
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hello at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to 20-minute leaders this
episode is all about career intentions
decisions
meet dr rony dudio god
a clinician researcher educator and
global opinion leader in dermatology
specifically on the topics of adverse
cutaneous drug reactions and deriver
disease
she mentors students and residents both
in israel and canada
and lead several research teams focusing
specifically on these topics
dr dudio god graduated from the technion
and conducted clinical and research
fellowships in the university of toronto
she is currently an assistant professor
in both of these institutions
the head of the dermatology program
bruce rappaport faculty of medicine
technion institute of technology israel
and the head of inflammatory and
autoimmune skin diseases unit
dermatology department emic medical
center israel
dr dudu god is engaged in major
international collaborations initiated
and leads global educational platforms
in dermatology and she's a member of
8400 the health network
we have um
a lot of different topics that
people may be expecting and and probably
that they won't be expecting
and you know your assistant professor
in two departments within the technique
on your head of the of dermatology but
you know your global opinion leader also
not in the sense of just dermatology but
also in the way that you do your
research and you're on your project some
of them the projects that you've already
we've already talked about offline are
just fascinating and i'd love to at
least get a taste of them in these short
20 minutes but but but just as
importantly get a taste of your own
personal journey and trajectory and
career and things that you realize now
that if you were to talk to your younger
self
and what you would say to her and so we
have a lot to unpack ronnie and thank
you very much for being here
thank you
well tell me a little bit about you know
your work in general what is you know
your work within dermatology well what
got you into dermatology
and then i'd love to hear a little bit
about how you look back at your career
okay great thank you and thank you so
much for having me
um
so currently i think i can define my my
professional passes
like in three ways i'm first of all i'm
a physician that's you know the basic
thing you know that's my goal in life to
treat patients to decrease suffering if
you ask me what is my main goal in life
is to decrease suffering
so being a be a physician that's the
first i'm a dermatologist doing the
advanced medical dermatology and doing
only you know hospital based uh
patients and mostly complicated and uh
basically severe skin
disorders then i'm a scientist you know
i love doing research i've been doing
that since i was you know in medical
school i have students and you know
researched it like for my soul it's
really like more of my introvert you
know i speak to my personality when i
get the time to think and to really take
into what i've seen my medical you know
practical work and then going to you
know more of the molecular basis and
thinking about how we can do it in a
better way
and then i'm also an educator i see
myself as somebody uh you know mentoring
students and residents i deeply care
about um
teaching and education in medicine in
general and in dermatology in particular
i'm established doing um
uh
global educational platforms in
dermatology and i'm very passionate
about that
but i think you know on top of those
three issues and i think you know
aspects of my professional life i see
myself as a global collaborator this is
something that i've been very interested
and you know passionate about in the
last two years
i think that today we live in a world
that is you know what connects me with
other people
it's our passion it's our professional
passion it's not where i'm located
geographically so you know i can have a
great calling you know in africa and we
can write together books and you know we
can do research together there's no
borders actually you know in science
and so i'm i really love it when you
connect to people that you know you
actually have the same goals and
motivations and you can you know have
this wonderful collaboration
so i'm very passionate about that
i love it okay so so
i i definitely want to make sure that we
we talk a little bit about these global
initiatives that you're working on but
before that
looking back at your career and some of
the insights that you that you now
understand that would have been relevant
for you but and are definitely relevant
to to young females or people in general
you know i think
we may be talking a little bit about
gender now but um but it's definitely
relevant for all different people that
are coming and with a seemingly
different background than what society
perhaps is is saying so share with me a
little bit about you know your own
career and a little bit of how you look
back at it yeah sure so um
you know i'm i was invited in the last
um
you know with women's day women
international day to the faculty of
medicine and detection to share my
journey so i had the time to reflect
back and to think you know what i've
learned and i realized that i've learned
so much
since i you know entered medical school
at the age of 20. crazy i'm 46 so it's
been 26 years of professional life then
you know and i wish somebody told me the
things that i know now so i want to
share them with you know i agree with
you it's not only women but women do
have specific issues so i think it's
really relevant for everybody but you
know me as a female i think some things
are worth and so i think you know
there's the i call it the challenging
triangle of life
so you actually have three vertices
right you have your family
then you have your career and then you
have yourself and how do you you know
coordinate yourself between these three
quarters
right
because you know when you know
in the time that you become a
professional person you know uh studying
20 30 you're also building your family
which is also very important right
and then for female you you know you're
pregnant and you know then you're
breastfeeding and then you have this
very important connection as a mom
so i was struggling with this triangle
like trying to do everything and uh
making many mistakes on the way
so i think there's some obstacles that i
realized one of them is the misleading
financial corporation i have i've i this
is the name i gave it like what is the
misleading financial population you know
when i was a resident
like you know all the money that i've
earned actually went to uh you know to
give to the babysitters and you know the
the home task that i was given i gave
and people other people were taking care
of my children you know
many hours in the day when i was at the
hospital twice a week that i had doing
night shifts
so many people also friends with good
intentions came to me and said well
ronnie doesn't make any sense
like you don't earn money because all
the money that you actually earn is you
know you you take it out and you pay
some other people you know to do this
stuff
and then you don't have money and you
don't see your kids like you don't see
them as much as you want right you see
them but you're not really you're not
close you're not spending many hours
with that so it doesn't make any sense
like what what like it makes more sense
just you know take the money or you know
you get and be with your kids
but this is a very short term you know
prisma
okay yes and that may last for many
years like for me five years of my
residency that was the situation and
even a bit more
so you know if you look in the short
term it makes sense right it doesn't
make any sense to earn money to give it
to somebody else and then it's all to
see your kids right but then if you
think it in the long term
you build yourself a career you build
yourself first financially even talking
only financially you know we had really
just about that
you know now i earn a lot of money and
you know you need to invest in your
career at the beginning
and you still you know even if for the
certain it doesn't make any sense for
the long-term redux i'm not even talking
you know about the you know the the the
self you know uh um inspiration you know
self fulfillment and all the other
important stuff and you know all of that
but even for ill only the financial so i
think this is one obstacles that people
need to understand and to to just bear
it in their mind when you know they're
they're doing what they're doing because
many times i have students and residents
and they tell me well i don't have time
to write the paper because
you know i need to i don't know clean
the house and i'm saying you don't like
to
outsource that you don't need to do that
that's the time you need to do that you
know what i mean look it's really you
need to think on work to make short term
the other thing
by the way i think that just just to to
to touch on that point you know that
there's a lot of
a lot of
very foundational understanding here now
that the compound interest that one gets
when they put in a dollar into their
401k
essentially multiplies itself tenfold by
the you know within a 30-year span by
the time you take it out and people
think that if they put ten dollars in
their 401k now they're gonna get those
same ten dollars in in the next 30 years
now they're actually gonna get you know
a few hundred dollars from those ten
dollars and and and here it's a little
bit harder to prove i think
mathematically what you're talking about
but but if you actually sit down and put
away you know the personal feelings and
the pre and the assumptions of society
you actually understand that it's very
much the case and and so i think you're
touching on a very very important point
and they're very happy and people
convince us especially because it's a
very sensitive issue it relates to our
children right right it's very like you
know it's it's a sense that you need to
be very strong about it the other thing
that i do want to mention and that's
from cheryl stenberg and you know uh uh
lenny in her book which i really like
and you know i encourage people to read
it she was talking about she talks about
the challenging marathon which i really
love you know what is the challenging
marathon think about a woman and when a
man running in the marathon of their
career right so the man when he runs
everybody likes cheering about you know
whoa you're such a you know you're so
great you're building the future of your
family you're if you're going to be
earning a lot of money you bring the
respect that is wonderful what do you
need some water maybe you know
take some you know snack bar with it
what is that what is the voice what are
the audience of the women of the female
right of the woman running and i was
running i'm still running i know what
what is the i know the audience very
well the audience is like oh you're
right
but where where are the kids
where are your kids right now you're
running you take the time to run and you
take the pleasure to fulfill yourself
but then where your kids somebody else
is taking care of them well and you do
you really know what was in school today
have you been talking to your daughter
lately you know making sure that she's
emotionally everything is okay
i mean it's nice that you want to
fulfill yourself
you know you have the advantage of doing
that
but you know we're just you know we're
just
we're just guessing what's
happening back home like you know what's
happening with your husband with your
kids is everything okay they would never
cheer up they would never tell i'm 26 of
30 26 years of fury i confront in one
hand people who said to me wow good for
you you're doing the right thing
that's really you know personal
experience and i think when you when you
understand what when you do not expect
the audience to be a supportive audience
when the expectation and you know you
just say i know this is what this is the
voice that i'm gonna hear but that's
okay
it's just okay i'm not expecting
anything else
so i think this is one thing that i
learned not to expect and then i'm not
you know i'm not i do not have any you
know um
drawbacks like i i just i'm not
disappointed i know the voice
and the third thing is so
so what so just to make sure you know
the takeaway here
it's less about
you know trying to say okay
let's change the way we communicate in
the expectations we're saying okay let's
maybe maybe it's a good start let's
understand the expectations and
understand what societal norms are
accept them disagree with them owned
that disagreement and okay try to
convince anybody expectation
you know i was always trying to convince
the the audience to be supportive
that that's a loose game like you're not
going to like it's not going to happen
otherwise you know it's otherwise they
really support you to begin with and
it's not much or they don't and that's
okay it's their issue it's not yours but
you need to know that there is no way
you know it's just that is the way and
just you know don't don't be
be like a shelter like don't don't take
it
and then i think there are two other
things that i realize more is i think
for me as a female that is one is our
instinct to please
you know i i i don't know if it's the
way we're raised and but i see also my
friends like you know we feel
uncomfortable saying no
when we get to do something again can
you please ask help me can you please
and you know you like you want to say
yes you want to help everybody you want
to be the good girl
and when you have a career
and when you're you have a career that
and your time is so limited you need to
say yes no you need to say learn not to
say yes to say no i'm sorry i can't do
that
and you know and just you know it's so
hard you would you couldn't imagine i
don't know i don't know if you know that
feeling but it's so it's so hard for
females
to uh you know to say no
and i've learned that and it's still
hard for me to say just no i'm sorry i'm
not able to do that i'm not able to help
you now i'm not able to
you know to have lunch with you or i'm
not able to put dinners for whatever
family member
because i don't have the time other
maybe other people can do that i don't
have the time so i think you know you
just need to remember those are the main
things
and then i think the you know what are
the travel tips for a great career is to
remember good enough is enough
i think this is really for all genders
right
i you know i'm a perfectionist like i'm
always have to be like and i learned
through that it's really
it's it's a bad thing it doesn't work
good you need to be comfortable with
good enough
and just you know
just fine and if you have you know
drawbacks and you know you're you're
having something that you're not 100
that's okay you know you're still
running
it's not you know it's a marathon you
know it's not a sprint you're just still
running and and i remember my mentor
professor neil scheer my beloved mentor
from the university of toronto saturn
irani you know what it's important you
wake up you come to the hospital and
still doing what you're doing and
although we have some you know difficult
days you you continue to do it
you still come and continue you know
driving that car
you know and i think this is very
important so we talked a bit about
outsourcing and i think outsourcing is
my main main you know if you said to me
in my building what is the one tip that
you want to say to young people
outsource
so my grandmother my blood grandmother
um who passed away
at the age of 16 she already i think
understood who she is like you know sure
this is my personality my character my
ambition and she said to me something i
would never forget she said to me ronnie
you know it really doesn't
the the talents don't care who fold them
but your kids will deeply care who you
know tells them the story before they go
to sleep
and
that was like my you know my main thing
that i've you know followed in my life i
was just out i'm still outsourcing
everything whatever i believe to do i
don't need i'm not doing
and the time that i've had
you know at home i make sure i make
you know impactful and
uh you know really meaningful time with
my beloved ones
with my kids with my husband you know
with my family with my friends
like i really try just to keep as much
time as i can when i'm not working with
mine you know with the dear people in my
life
and when i'm with them to be with them
so i think this is very very important
because i see many people who have
career but then at the end of 40 years
of career they have no friends or the
families already you know gave gave up
on them because they were never taking
the time to invest in you know
relationships and relationships
you know you need to invest in
relationships it's not something it's
not like you know
you need to be there for them where
they're sick you need to be there for
them when they're not feeling well
emotionally or physically where you're
for the dear people in your life
so and also to have great moments like
you know happy moments you know and you
know
do fun things together so i think i
think in life what is important which
makes us happy is really relationships
and i think you need to invest them
although you have great right but the
only thing you can do it's like 24 hours
and you know 24 hours a day like you
cannot invent something else yet
so you just our source other things even
if you need to pay money for that
right
yeah i mean i think you bring up some
some really interesting considerations
about both personal fulfillment
relationships investments prioritization
and understanding at the end where where
it counts and where it doesn't count and
how do you
balance between short term and long term
and it is a balance because you could be
at the hospital 24 7. um
you do choose to come home and tell the
story to the kids at night that is what
counts that is the biggest roi
but uh and and and that balance and that
great balance
it's exactly you know going back to the
triangle trying to you know and it's
okay sometimes in life it doesn't have
to be
and you know all the time balance like
there were time in my life that i was
like full in my career because i had
advanced and you know so maybe in one
year i was like most in my career but
then another year i was you know taking
some you know some the leg off the gas
and going back being more at home so it
doesn't have to be at the same moment
this harmony but but i think it has to
be in your mind and you have to be
focused on making sure that you you did
you remember those you know three
important burgesses in your life
and i do want to say before i want to
make sure that i give credit to my
mother because my mother she's a she has
she's a professor she has a wonderful
career and she came from a very
if i i had you know and i have to say my
parents were very supportive and my
husband is really supportive so i was
very lucky and even though being very
lucky
and still it was a great state it was a
big struggling so i can't even imagine
how is it if you come from a home it's
not supportive and you don't have like
you know my god was a role model for me
yeah i knew how she had a career i saw
her was you know kind of if if i was not
left who i am today that would be the
surprising part actually you know it's
like it's not a big deal that i did what
i did in a way you know what i mean
because i'm not a great role model i had
supportive family i had my husband who
really supports me so big deal you know
like everything was there for me and it
still wasn't struggle michael it still
wasn't struggling so you know it is hard
and i think it's okay to say that it's
hard
i you know sometimes you know there's
international woman day and they come
very like successful women and they say
well it's all in your head you know
you're just like the same and
the sorry i may not
like are you kidding me are you kidding
me
like you know why are you lying why are
not saying the truth that it's hard that
sometimes your kids will cry when you
have to go on the plane to the meeting
and they will say you know i had my my
kids they were hard times you know i had
to go to new york uh to work there for
months and my son was very upset with
that when we came back to israel and
remember we went to a vacation in a lot
and my husband does windsurfing so my
son you know he went to this to the to
the sea to the windsurfing i stayed at
the beach with my son and my son was
crying for half an hour i hate you i
don't want to see you i don't want to be
with you where's my father and all you
know israeli people were looking at me
like who's this harmful mother like what
does she do to her son
see there are moments of pain and i
wanted to disappear at that moment but
now you know it went away everything is
okay my son is so close to me and we're
great so there will be these moments
and you're not alone like it happens to
everybody that's the price that you pay
you know there's no free lunch and we
need to talk about it we need to say
that
you know at least somebody told that to
me at the end it's uh
i i i first of all thank you for for
being so open and and sharing
you know at the end i think it goes back
to to that same triangle that same
understanding that at the end you know
if if you have the goal
of you know and i think every probably
every parent and i'm not a parent yet so
i it's hard for me to say but i'm
guessing that every parent would agree
that their goal is to bring to provide
the best the best life for their kids
right and that's the end result it
doesn't really matter what profession
the best quality of life for their kids
their grandkids etc
and if you look at everything that we've
talked about now you're this is where
your priorities are and you and what
you're saying is sometimes we get
confused perhaps
and we think that these short-term
events are indicative of quality of life
or long-term happiness when really their
their noise their obstacles their their
struggles that we should be able to deal
with but
society doesn't really allow us to deal
with them just like you said in that
situation where you felt like a bad
mother you know sitting on that beach
even though that that wasn't the case it
was a single instance
and you know that moment could have
brought me to say you know i'm giving up
on everything
right because there was so much pain in
that moment so much pain and
you know listening to his crying and
that was after i was one month in work
city and he was upset and that's okay
you know i i i
i just needed to understand and i
remember saying this is the price
this is the price and everything will be
okay because i really believe in what i
do and i you know i'm i believe you know
in the reason i'm in medicine and the
reason i'm doing research and science
and there's and i you know and nowadays
my son is really says to me you're my
inspiration mom except me then few days
ago he said you're inspiring
and that is i think a much much much
more important and amazing gift than a a
month here or a month there a story here
or story there at the end that's you
know that that's the that's the
investment for long term for
for him to also be a good parent later
on and to provide inspiration to those
around him and uh dr roni i i really
want to thank you for the time you know
we you the we we all everything that we
talk about now you know it doesn't even
relate directly with with your
day-to-day work and and the way that
you're working in medicine and the
global collaborations and projects i'm
i'm already going to invite you and book
you for another episode because we need
to talk about them because they're just
as inspiring but but i'm leaving this
conversation with
with with better understanding and
energy towards you know
prioritizations and and balance or or
the fact that it's okay to have some
imbalance sometimes yes yes
thank you very very much thank you so
much it was wonderful thank you